Doug Gottlieb box sports radio debuts on
Fox Sports Radio Monday April 24th at
3:00 p.m. Eastern now that's for sure
because last time you were here last
week we didn't know if you were maybe
gonna get the Oklahoma State job what
happened they decided that retention of
staff and retention of current players
was was the most important thing
apparently Mike Boynton went in and
wowed him in an interview and I did not
or I don't know like I haven't gotten
the feedback I got from Mike holder the
athletic director was we just I felt
like I couldn't hire somebody who hadn't
coach before boost I thought I would
assume when I hung up that phone that it
was going to be somebody Tom Crean Tim
Jankovic somebody of you know who had a
resume that I couldn't compete with on
paper how were you told I was told I was
literally landed from Oklahoma in New
York City I was driving in and the phone
rang and you know like the range of
emotions when you see the athletic
director call you like this could be
this I you know I'm a positive person I
was like all right this is it and so
when I talked to you you were in Atlanta
changing planes yeah so you would just
interviewed and then the day before yeah
you so then you flew to Atlanta to
connect and then you were going to New
York yeah and then you land in New York
after you spoke to us in Atlanta yeah
and then you got the news yeah Wow
yeah I was weird is that I you know on
the on the plane I was texting with
people I was texting with weird my
brother and I my brother was gonna join
me on staff miles Simon works at ESPN he
was gonna be part of my staff
Todd Licklider who had been a butler's a
scout for the Celtics and there's a
couple other people who I was I was
thinking about and then we were lining
up all right who do we immediately call
all the all the different targets do we
know these people's parents do we know
these people a you people and we had a
couple who were fifth you know part of
the game now as fifth-year transfers and
we had some good connections with a
couple fifth years so we were just you
know I just I wanted to if somebody said
go hit the ground running and start
making some calls and so I got the call
and you go up and then you go down but
is it just coaching Oklahoma State or do
you want to coach I would like to coach
I would like to coach it has to be the
right thing because as
as I one of the great gonna be an
assistant coach well one I have a great
job to you put yourself into a pool of
put to put itself into a much larger
pool of people don't get me wrong it's
gonna take an athletic director who has
a unique vision and has has faith in my
ability to surround myself people who
know what I don't know
but you're gonna put yourself my
brother's been assistant coach for over
20 years okay the he be helped build San
Diego State from nothing to a powerhouse
Cal Berkeley they went to four
tournaments in six years and won the
league and at Oregon State they hadn't
made the tournament in 25 years second
year there they they did so and he has
been unable to get a head coaching job
he's been close but he's been I'm it's
really really hard to get these jobs why
put yourself in a pool of you know 3,000
candidates when you can be great again
different and unique but in a small and
besides like I have a better job I make
plenty of money and I may get a chance
to move back to Southern California
where where my mom lives where all our
friends are our kids will be happy so
would I would I entertain it yes
absolutely the right thing I'd love a
shot but it have to be the right thing
last time you hear you talked about
Steve Alford that you heard it was a
done deal huh what happened I'm led to
believe that the buyout which is eight
million dollars on his contract was
prohibitive and the thought was when
when when Indiana first got to the point
where where they were thinking about
making a genetic director calling you my
wife that she has a special ring that's
my wife okay so for you she know what
you're doing today
she she does know but she has no times I
said I'm going up to see Dan and she's
like oh Dan's gonna give you the
business for not going over to his house
yes to watch the game on Saturday night
do you want to get into this we get into
it I I'm like blah I I'm I'm first of
all dude you invited me to your house I
you said man cave I thought you meant
here well I was gonna do it here if
there was gonna be enough guys you know
a little bit larger we would have done
it here from the well I'm not the only
one who blew you off is of what you're
saying
oh no no there were other guys who were
actually out of town okay but you know I
was I was in town did you think it was a
faux invite I thought it was a little
pity invite
that's that's honestly what I know
because I I wouldn't want you if a pity
party because you didn't get the
Oklahoma State job but then you texted
me that oh don't worry
I'm gonna invite I was gonna invite Mike
Boynton instead like I better hurt dude
that was some that was some high-quality
trash talk
okay now what led up to that is
I I reached out to Doug Doug goes hey
you know didn't get the job but I'm part
of Fox Sports Radio and I'm really happy
proud of that line up and if you need a
drinking buddy this is Saturday morning
and I said okay it's nine thirty four
and I go yeah hey you got come on up
we'll have a either my man cave or my
house so he goes oh let me check with
Aaron Rodgers he could be having Scotch
in the city yeah so you say the text if
you like I mean I know that okay I could
show you the lack of text after that
when you didn't check if you check with
Aaron Rodgers didn't get back to me and
then I text him at nine o'clock that
night I go I guess you're not coming to
my house and he it was bad form out of
me I mean look what happened the you
know sort of post-traumatic stress from
losing the Oklahoma State job then he
couldn't you know remember to text me
but you could remember to text Aaron
Rodgers yes pause Dan we're analyzing
this right now the situation you got
caught in what's called a celebrity
showdown got lead kept his options open
to go hang out with Aaron Rodgers blame
him yeah because you're right down the
street he can hang out with you again
the Aaron Rodgers New York City call
probably doesn't happen every day and
Gottlieb kept his options open for Aaron
Rodgers he waited too long to get back
to you and he missed both boats yeah and
I got this and I got to watch the game
my kids and part of it was I did get the
are you really going to go to the city
or go to Dan Patrick's house instead of
watching these games you can watch them
on Sunday which I did this was a
Saturday night only I know and I thought
maybe my family was on the west coast
already looking for housing and then I
thought that poor guys at home yeah let
me pick up his spirits and let him come
over it was a pity invite
it was a pity invite but I was still
inviting you it was real i real invite
it's it's going to be one to which it's
an opportunity missed and that's on me
Mitch last time it doesn't happen again
Wow that's it it's one and done one and
done at my house so okay so what
happened to UCLA yeah
I'm led to believe when the discussions
initially began I think you say it was
like look if we let him go
well you know I thought think the
thought was we'll figure out the buyout
when we figure out the buyout and then
as he got as it got real
now UCLA is like you want him
eight million dollars he's got a great
recruiting class coming in and Indiana
said you know what we're still a little
conflicted as to whether or not we want
him anyway eight million dollars is a
ridiculous amount let's move on and
frankly Archie Miller is a great option
he's a better coach to have than Steve
Alford I think so because there's not
the whatever sense of baggage not that
he has personal baggage but the night
baggage I think that cuts that off
Archie was a great coach fundamentally
sound fits the area we'll recruit his
ass off just like his brother did at
Arizona yeah probably probably everybody
ended up being happier but when when I
said it was what I was told when I was
told it was done
everybody in basketball his total was
done so please don't think that like I
was Edward or reporting that's done it's
a signed contract that's just the sense
everybody had and UCLA was worrying
about their next options and it didn't
end up becoming a reality well I did see
some people who would have been in line
for the UCLA job so where they were
lining up the Jets you have on the
runway well you have to I mean there are
lots yeah maybe Billy Donovan right
that's that you have to live you're a
good athletic director you have to
always have what five names in your
drawer and then wasn't Alford didn't one
of his top guys is recruits his from
Indiana
yes Wilkes yeah because then I thought
if you know then all of a sudden he goes
back to Indiana and then all of a sudden
this kid D commits and then place it
Indiana but and that's that's the way
the game works and you know like right
now with like Georgetown being open and
Dayton being open and even Oklahoma
State or you know all of those guys it's
a free-agent bonanza Cal with the
coaching change at Cal that's a
interesting hire with liking Jones
getting the job now the sudden you know
guys get out of there letter and you
know if you're a really good recruit a
really good head coach you're figuring
out who can I get in them all right
we'll come back with Doug we'll look at
Vegas is looking at a favorite here I
don't know if that's a surprise to
people but we'll talk about the matchups
here and sort of the fallout from I do
want to ask you about this I brought
this up to McLovin at the beginning of
the show where NBA scouts have said they
don't look at performance in the in the
tournament as a great indicator of where
somebody should be drafted I'm gonna ask
you if that's true or not and do they
make a mistake one way or another with
that will continue with Doug Gottlieb
right after the
I just saw one of the Vegas books the
favorite to win the championship is
Gonzaga how surprising is that over
North Carolina really surprising yeah
really surprising one because it's North
Carolina - North Carolina's been there
before and look Gonzaga shot the shot
the eyes out of the basketball on
Saturday night and took down Xavier but
you know they nearly lost to West
Virginia and they nearly lost
Northwestern after having a big lead
it's not like they've been infallible in
this tournament and you don't really
know like do I think with a week to
prepare for South Carolina's matchup
zone I think they'll be pretty good but
you don't know what they will look like
against the type of athleticism that
they're going to face when they've faced
super athletic teams they've looked just
ok and Nigel Williams cos they're best
players try to play hero ball against
West Virginia that didn't go well I
don't know how he'll play against South
Carolina I would have if I was in Vegas
I would have said the favorite was
Carolina I think I felt like last
night's game was the national
championship game I want to ask you
about the end of the Carolina Kentucky
game monk hits the big shot and then
there's just transition where Carolina
gets the game-winner with with me so
should Calipari have called timeout
yeah yeah kid because and the classic
reason that look robe Williams is not
calling timeout never calls timeout yeah
and he's all he like that's just his
belief let the kids play find the open
man they found Luke Mae who made some
great plays down the stretch and he made
two free throws he made a great outlet
pass Tove on the floor tied up the ball
and that makes the game-winner
like I would hope that Luke Mae does not
have a girlfriend if he doesn't he's
gonna have himself a good couple of days
here in Chapel Hill but the reason you
don't call timeout is you don't want the
defense to set itself right so why not
call timeout to set your defense and you
could have made adjustments because
they're like Kentucky's lineup was an
offensive baseline up change put you
know put a better defensive group on the
floor and you give yourself a better
opportunity to get a stop that's it's
one of the things that is missing one in
college basketball - John Calipari like
I think that if you think he can't coach
go back and look at Kentucky a month and
a half ago they were a disaster
defensively true they became a very good
team but the things that have are
missing are some of these little things
years ago they lost the national
championship game and they didn't have
Willie cauley-stein and that really hurt
only lost UConn but if you look at the
last minute and how he didn't understand
the math of when to foul and how to
lengthen the game you look at last night
there's there's some little things there
that either he or his staff need to
nudge him and and he's missing on and I
think looked at does it change the guy
making a shot maybe maybe they throw it
in anywhere maybe they lose in overtime
but there are some little things I think
that he could make adjustments to he's
won one national title there at what
point because there they expect you know
you're gonna go to the Final Four or
we're gonna be you know a title
contender which they were a title
contender they don't even get to the
Final Four not that his jobs in jeopardy
but his job being called into question
at what point or does he get to that
point in Kentucky or is he on
scholarship I think he's good I mean I
think he gets the entire look that's one
of the reasons he changes the narrative
right he makes the narrative about the
players and and the program and getting
him to the NBA like that's my that's my
first and most important thing that's
really smart right just like change the
narrative it's not about winning a title
it's about winning in the NBA and
winning in life but I also think it
speaks to the tournament basketball is
just changed because there's the
freshmen are so young in comparison to
what everybody else is thrown out there
I mean like look at the experience what
North Carolina has I'm like does that
mean that Bill Self doesn't know what
he's doing or they'd bill self somehow
the legacy like I I hear it and it just
it's insane to me that you could say
well these guys are chokers they're not
coming up I I think you based the team
based but did it get better are they
competitive but Kansas should have want
to Kansas City come on look there's some
they played 10 times in Kansas City
Kansas wins 9 Oregon which the better
team I think there's big disappointment
there was a big disappointment but it's
not his fault that they missed shots
that they normally make and they weren't
missing they weren't joking that there's
missing shots
additionally they had the issue Josh
Jackson found trouble yeah and and with
the flaw there I actually talked to
Danny Hurley before before Rhode Island
played organ and you know we talked
about because I know organ really well
and he said what do you do I said well
the problem is that Dylan Brooks is the
your four-man right so who do you want
to put on
Brooks he said Jared Terrell but I don't
want him and here's where Danny smart I
don't want him guarding him in the first
half
picking up foul trouble the problem with
Bill Self is he had to have Josh Jackson
on Dillon Brooks he doesn't really have
a backup for him they don't have any
depth once he got into foul trouble it
forever set them back and then they got
tight when they got down and they could
never kind of get over that hump
Frank Martin's 51 great job at South
Carolina normally coaches used this
platform to jump to another job is Frank
Martin South Carolina's coach for a long
time I don't I don't know I mean I
always people always thought that when
the Miami job came open he's from Miami
coach to Miami senior high school that
that would instead they went to coach L
so maybe if that one comes open that
makes sense
Frank is there he's wired very very
differently and I think South Carolina
becomes this becomes a place to which
kind of like Spurrier he's been able to
take them to Heights they've never seen
before
he's got an athletic director he's got a
great relationship with I don't think
you need to chase it as much as you
previously did and I also don't like
he'd he doesn't strike me as the next
Kentucky guy the next Carolina game he
did that we in the number one recruit
Zion Williamson from South Carolina I
could he yeah I think he's from North
Carolina could he I mean that would that
would that's what needs to change in
order to keep Frank Martin there I
remember Kevin Garnett's from South
Carolina you know he went his last year
high school we went to Farragut in
Chicago if you can simply build a fence
around South Carolina and keep all those
kids home like Cindy Ruiz thorn well
then you got a shot probably where Zion
Williamson from straight out of
Spartanburg South Carolina
okay there we go yeah I think there yeah
did you say I wanted to also ask you
about NBA scouts have talked about they
look at March Madness and they don't
really derive anything from that I think
that's BS well I think it's BS too but I
I don't know how much value you put in
to McLovin what was the expression that
was used to you or that you heard oh
just sit for one thing the scouts don't
really get good see to those games so
they don't go to them and the freshmen
are more valuable basically freshmen
don't do well in the tournament but they
still go high in the draft well yeah but
I do think there are guys that move up
in the draft based upon their
performance in the
see a tournament right who have you seen
thorn wells gonna move up Yeah right
yeah I mean like Jordan bells like
Jordan Bell suddenly people talking
about NBA player Jim Bell six foot eight
he's the most athletic most athletic kid
yeah remaining in the term he's a freak
but like he should be playing football
not basketball in the NBA like I don't
know where you put him on a ball you'll
get a dream on Green type that he can do
he can't shoot like I can't shoot you
can't handle green like Jordan okay but
whose stock went up and whose stock went
down why Tyler Dorsey stock is gonna
gonna go up he's shot the lights out the
bascomb you know but he's in between a 1
& 2
he can really shoot but he's not really
creating his own shot like they're
playing some zone to hide him a little
bit defensively so to anybody who says
it doesn't it it's it you can go through
and you know go back Corey Brewer at
Florida remember like he got drafted
probably way above his level but it's
based upon riding the wave Torrey and
green on that team got draft in the
second round draft long so ball draft
status get hurt it on I think it got
hurt not because they lost but because
the way in which he looked against the
type of athleticism the Kentucky had he
looked like that shot takes a while to
get off he looked like he couldn't get
it off the Aaron Fox looked too athletic
for him he looked more normal now that
doesn't mean he drops out of the lottery
but I think that every Scout that every
Scout who watches that game says well
yeah Memphis got a chance now to go
ahead long football because he's so
explosive and like the most important
thing in the NBA would you take him over
mon-sol ball I would take Lonzo because
I think he makes everybody better but I
understand that the hardest thing get is
somebody who guards these point guards
or lead guards in the NBA and the Aaron
Fox can do that like I don't know if
he'll do it at the level he's doing it
now immediately in the NBA but
eventually he will and if he develops a
jump shot he has a chance to be as good
or better player to me though Lonzo
immediately makes everybody better he
has a certain just a genocide qualms
about how he plays that when you watch
him like wow he puts the ball right in
the right spot and pros are gonna love
playing with it so how's this play out
next weekend Final Four I again I think
it's a hard matchup for North Carolina
to match up with Dylan Brooks
the power for like Luke May can't guard
him that can't happen
so you probably have to move Justin
Jackson onto him but I do think Carolina
has the depth there
I think Carolina wins that game I think
Gonzaga beats South Carolina and in a
year in which we thought hey it's
anybody's ballgame
you still have to one seeds going on
yeah and I think that North Carolina
wins I think the Joel berries if healthy
is a better big game player than Nigel
Williams casas I think it's one of the
few games in which Kennedy makes his
size will be effective
instead of sometimes being out athlete
on the floor and I think that that
Justin Jackson's improvement as a shoe
dry I think he's too big and too long
for for Gonzaga swings I think North
Carolina wins which is crazy because
last year was supposed to be the year
this year wasn't supposed it's their
Redemption tour speaking of which I'll
talk to you next time you'll be at Fox
here coming up it'd be a lot of fun I'm
excited to follow Cowherd and follows
you in the lineup and it's awesome so
I'm very excited about the opportunity
m-- yeah how do you think we do mean you
know us against like we'd have a
starting five against another Radio
Network basketball or yeah how heard
claims to have played in high school
Clay Travis was a lawyer I'm trying to
think who like rasilla is a hack dude
like we're Cilla's got he's got him like
he's got him a kale game but at the
other and he's like Rick Mahorn
defensively did I don't think they have
anybody else who can play over there
Steve and ace you can't have played at
know you can't play can't play no but
like can you move it like you'd like to
move all you have to do is set up shop
in the corner that's me
that's you want you want corner what do
you like it that's three in the corner I
got greenie on me so I'm gonna score on
him well you can score in the post on
green no that's not really that's not
really hard
greenie strikes me as a flopper what
about makes me bomani Jones can he play
no chance
Laird can seems like the marching band
wasn't he a lot of reach huh good
wingspan does have big his law his big
hands long arms but I do not think he
can pull he's got et fingers he does he
has super super long phone oh that's
super crazy crazy long thing yes but
that doesn't limit or camp no chance
yeah lobe [ __ ] suffers from no acetal
have you ever seen photos of livers in
the leg he needs he needs some of those
implants it's a one-piece he's gonna
thank you Doug for stopping by the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience